my brother's better than me I don't like
to admit it but he's better than me
[Music]
I'm Daniel vogelbach I'm here to answer
the internet would you rather face only
lefties for the rest of your career or
travel on the road on buses minor league
style forever
oh man
um I guess I'm traveling on buses minor
league style forever because I want to
make more money so I need to face some
rice
would you rather hit an inside the park
home run or pitch as a position player
and strike someone out oh gosh I would
probably pitch as a position player and
strike someone else out I I feel like
you hit a triple a triple in Chicago
this year
yeah I just rather hit it over the fence
on Triple but like uh no it wasn't back
because it bounced away from hap so it
was kind of like not like a stand-up it
was like I had to go one of those were
like I had to go
not not hard
that's why I'd have a chance to strike
someone out because it'd be under
hitting speed would you rather never hit
another home run or never drink another
cup of coffee and get my caffeine from
somewhere else so it never never drink
another cup of coffee
no caffeine and you got
it oh man yeah
yeah but I still no I'd have to find I
still no uh no caffeine so you saw your
uh old teammate the other day uh slide
into third base losing the cell phone
out of his pocket oh yeah okay
what is the weirdest thing that could
fall out of your pocket while running
the basis this is the weirdest thing in
your everyday life something that you
carry around or I guess my wallet would
you ever uh could you ever imagine step
up to play with this foot no way no I
mean yeah no way the only other thing is
like not on my pocket but my chains
broke while I'm you know playing but
yeah there's no way that yeah yeah I
know there's no way I'd have a phone in
my pocket Noah would you ever play
without your chains on uh I always have
my cross on so yeah and then I played I
used to play with the it's actually
funny we were in Miami before that with
Pittsburgh and my black diamond broke
because I stood back in a second I'm
like I ain't playing with this anymore
so like that was like I'm done with that
too start bench cutch in the Major
League those three uh I don't know if
you're a movie guys so if you haven't
seen be seen Major League The Sandlot oh
I got you okay start bench okay I'm
gonna start
Major League bench to sand lot and cut
Field of Dreams oh
because they're always like to feel the
dreams is the I know but I'm more the
other ones are fun like I don't know who
is the last pitcher on Earth you would
charge the mound against probably past
probably Nolan Ryan yeah yeah that one's
that was Infamous right I feel like if
you you charge them out on that one you
bet you you better bring it you're gonna
be in it for a long time he was not
[ __ ] around no he wanted it do you
think you could throw a football farther
than a 1940s Heisman winner who was the
1940 Heisman winner I'll take my chance
on my Sofia I think I can throw it
further than them
yeah I'm taking my chance against Tom I
think yeah I'll take my chance would you
rather be stuck in Jurassic Park
or what is that I haven't seen Jumanji
what I'm not a movies guy I'm weird but
I'll tell you right now I decided I
don't think I want to be stuck in
Jurassic Park but maybe Jumanji may be
worse
I'm not a movie
all right
[Laughter]
I'm like old like if I have to find a
movie I like like I'll watch Remember
the Titans 100 times if you had one free
throw and if you make it you get a
million bucks but if you miss it you
never get to text again when you shoot a
heck yeah I'm shooting it I'm making it
yeah yeah I'm shooting it I used to play
a little bit yeah yeah I'm I'm shooting
the free throw did you you played a
football ground too uh just one year I
just did it and I I hated the coach I
loved it but he wouldn't let me play he
wanted me to only play football I'm like
dude no like yeah so I'm like no I
played like he like let me play
everywhere like I play nose guard
um I played some oh like uh left guard
they let me run the ball some like I was
like do whatever but a freshman in high
school but the problem was I wanted to
have fun with my boys and I they made me
play varsity and I started and I just
got I was 14 just kidding and down in
Florida like that high school football
is good you know you're playing and I'm
just getting like every night I'm just
getting crushed you know I'm like this
is not what I envisioned as big as a
freshman I was big yeah like
um but I was like I could like still
Mike I could move so it's like that's
why they wanted me up I'm like no I just
wanted to play I just wanted to play for
fun like I didn't want to go out there
and get crushed every night and we
weren't very good so it made it even
worse I'm gonna go play baseball yeah
yeah
but like yeah we still play basketball
in the off season and hang out and stuff
like that I enjoyed running around
jumper I don't know my brother's better
than me I don't like to admit it but
he's better than me I think uh from the
free throw line right now no warm-ups no
warm-ups and free throws how many hidden
I'm going over 50 yes yeah I have to
take a shot to it yeah oh man
Mary [ __ ] kill
shares Fruit by the Foot sure what's
Fruit by the Foot
by the foot I gotta send you snacks too
you're gonna make You're gonna laugh at
me now what the heck shark bites
yeah
next time I come here no podcast we just
watch a movie and what movie oh
most recently made you cry man are you a
crier yeah yeah I'll tell you one that
gets me and I don't know I think it's
because my family's so invested in it is
Radio
like my family's big into like my mom
was like the head of Special Olympics of
Florida my sister's a kindergarten
special needs teacher so like radio
definitely is the one that I could watch
it all the time and I still yeah for
sure thank you brother yeah thank you
man I appreciate you guys
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out